[Musica]
stanche nel 1972 la scienziata cinese yu
youtube scopo el artemisina una potente
sostanza estratta da una delle piante
della medicina tradizionale cinese che
la portava nel 2015 a vincere il premio
nobel per la medicina
datemi cena infatti è l'elemento
fondamentale di una delle medicine più
importanti che abbiamo contro la malaria
la manovra come sapete è un'infezione
dovuta al a un organismo unicellulare il
plasmodium falciparum che uccide ogni
anno più di 400.000 persone a fronte di
oltre 200 milioni di infetti la temi
cena quando usata in combinazione con
altre medicine è in grado di ridurre in
alcuni casi la mortalità di anche il 70
per cento però la produzione di
artemisina dalla pianta è lenta e
costosa e infatti nel 2006
un'equipe di scienziati guidati da
ricercatori dell'università della
california a berkeley ha ingegnerizzato
un lievito modificando nel dna che fosse
in grado di produrre il precursore
dell'artemisinina velocemente e con un
costo per dose di soli 25 centesimi di
dollaro e importante notare che il
lievito da solo non è in grado di
produrre artemisina neanche quando viene
stimolato 4 miliardi di anni di
evoluzione sul nostro pianeta ci hanno
portato a pensare che tutto ciò che vivo
tutto ciò che vediamo intorno a noi sia
il risultato di un processo naturale di
nascita crescita mutazione selezione che
tutto quello che è vero per i piccoli
organismi che vivono nei nostri laghi
nei nostri fiumi se avevo anche per le
30 trilioni di cellule
che compongono il nostro corpus delle
macchine piccolissime che lavorano da
soli o insieme a molte molte altre due
le basi chimiche che sostengono la vita
che quindi tutto ciò che è vivo sia il
risultato dell'evoluzione e invece come
abbiamo visto non è così la scienza che
si occupa di ingegnerizzare sistemi
biologici si chiama biologia sintetica
parte dalla conoscenza dei meccanismi di
assemblaggio dei sistemi biologici però
arrivare a soluzioni completamente a
volte radicalmente nuove la biologia
sintetica però questo esercizio diciamo
non è un esercizio scientifico o un
capriccio la biologia sintetica una
miriade di applicazioni in una grande
quantità di campi come ad esempio non
solo la protezione di medicine o di bio
sintetici ma anche la patologia digitale
la produzione e sicurezza del cibo
la biosensoristica ad esempio quella
ambientale o così un po più esotiche
come la sintesi di batteri che sono in
grado di distruggere l'inquinamento come
nel caso della baio remediation o le
terapie le terapie cellulari
il problema della biologia sintetica
come di molte altre scienze è che si
basa su lenti e costosi processi di try
allenero di prova e di dove cioè si
prova una certa struttura se funziona e
bene altrimenti la si modifica
leggermente e si prova di nuovo
e questo è come cercare una soluzione in
uno spazio un'associazione un problema
in uno spazio delle soluzioni enormi che
è quello della variabilità genetica e in
maniera molto inefficiente possiamo e
dobbiamo fare di più
come vi starete chiedendo beh ovviamente
usando il computer nel mio lavoro di
tutti i giorni mi occupo di creare
macchine super intelligenti e lo faccio
essendo a capo di un'equipe di persone
che sono anch'esse super intelligenti
che qualche volta crea
ha qualche problema noi ci occupiamo di
intelligenza artificiale quindi ci
occupiamo di quegli algoritmi ai quali è
possibile insegnare a leggere a vedere e
in generale a ottenere risultati
originali basandosi sui dati e
applichiamo questi algoritmi a alla
biologia chiamiamo questa nuova
disciplina ingegneria cellulare
l'intelligenza artificiale come sapete è
una delle tendenze tecnologiche più
importanti non solo ora ma lo sarà anche
per i prossimi decenni
e infatti come abbiamo durante la prima
rivoluzione industriale ridefinito il
lavoro in funzione del motore
il motore a vapore nei nei prossimi 20
anni
ri di fini definiremo il lavoro in
funzione dell'intelligenza artificiale e
della nostra associazione
adesso quando si parla di intelligenza
artificiale di solito si parla di quei
processi in background per esempio
quelli che fanno funzionare i nostri
smart assistenza nei nostri cellulari
oppure quelli che
ci sono delle nelle macchine automatiche
la maggior parte di questi algoritmi
sono algoritmi che imparano dai tempi
cioè gli si fanno vedere tanti tante
immagini ad esempio di gattino i gattini
di internet in maniera tale che possano
riconoscere un gatto in un'immagine che
non hanno mai visto recenti avanzamenti
nel campo dell'intelligenza artificiale
però hanno portato a creare algoritmi
che sono in grado di imparare le regole
del sistema e creare da sé gli esempi
sui quali imparare e come se per esempio
uno scacchista conoscendo benissimo le
regole del gioco
invece di imparare la strategia degli
scacchi guardando le partite dei grandi
maestri giocasse una miriade di partite
contro se stesso con l'obiettivo
ovviamente di vincere
imparando la strategia dalla dallo
svolgimento ed ai risultati delle varie
partite è una delle conseguenze di
questo processo è che questo scacchista
non avrà il byas dovuto al fatto di
aveva imparato dal lavoro degli altri
ora cosa succederebbe se noi
insegnassimo alla nostra alle nostre
macchine le leggi che governano le leggi
chimiche e fisiche che governano i
processi biologici
beh è una delle cose che possiamo
osservare che l'evoluzione ci ha fornito
solo una delle possibili soluzioni a
tutti i problemi che i sistemi biologici
come la nostra cellula di lievito
abbiano dovuto affrontare e che le
nostre macchine senza il buyer's di 4
miliardi di selezione naturale possano
arrivare a delle soluzioni diverse
soluzioni che magari non sono
ottimizzate per la sopravvivenza in
condizioni avverse ma sono ottimizzate
per cose che sono più utili per noi come
ad esempio la sintesi di una medicina
contro la prossima pandemia
oppure
di una cellula in grado di uccidere
cellule di cancro e quindi la macchina
intelligente non risolve solo il
problema della velocità dell'innovazione
ma aumenta lo spazio delle soluzioni
dandoci la possibilità di creare
strutture nuove strutture che non sono
mai state realizzate e io riesco a
immaginare un futuro in cui la sinergia
tra la macchina e il sistema biologico
sia così organica da permetterci di
ridurre l'input umano di routine ed a
liberare la creatività del ricercatore
che doveva esclusivamente pensare a cosa
serviva la propria macchina biologica
invece di pensare a come realizzarla in
altre parole le nostre macchine
intelligenti ci diranno come realizzava
il nostro unicorno
vorrei concludere parlando delle
conseguenze ovvie consiglio ovviamente
delle conseguenze che possono risultare
dall'insegnate a una macchina disegnava
ai sistemi biologici
quanti di voi hanno letto frankenstein
la maggior parte di voi sicuramente
aveva visto uno dei tanti film basati
sul libro ecco quando ho iniziato a
lavorare in questo campo in questa
ingegneria cellulare con i fondi della
national science foundation e con i miei
collaboratori al sente forse allora
construction a san francisco
abbiamo pensato spesso a che cosa voglia
dire innovazione responsabile in un
campo come questo è quali siano le
conseguenze etiche e ovvio che aveva la
possibilità di creare macchine
biologiche che facciano quello che
vogliamo in un brevissimo tempo sia
molto importante non solo dal punto di
vista medico o dal punto di vista
addirittura economico e è anche ovvio
che l'innovazione responsabile non segue
il macchiavelli il fine per quanto
nobile non giustifica i mezzi
ed è importante ricordare
che questi algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale non sono da soli in grado di
creare una macchina biologica questi
algoritmi non sono così fondamentalmente
potenti da scavalcava l'uomo nelle
decisioni principali e poi come dice il
mio amico e collega di bucci non ditelo
assiri ma possiamo sempre staccare la
spina
secondariamente c'è ancora molta strada
da fare per i due il buyer's negli
algoritmi negli algoritmi di
intelligenza artificiale
gli algoritmi più avanzate che abbiamo
sono ancora delle scatole nere delle
black box
il cui funzionamento è molte volte
oscuro i cui risultati nonostante
straordinariamente accurati sono ancora
difficili da spiegare e questo
ovviamente vuol dire che è molto
difficile accorgersi di eventuali by us
e poterli rimuovere però come dicevo
prima la promessa di questa nuova
disciplina scientifica di questa
ingegneria cellulare e è molto grande
l'umanità deve pensare in maniera nuova
a risolvere problemi attuali e futuri
dobbiamo quindi abbandonare
secondo me questa idea dell'intelligenza
artificiale che abbiamo quella che ci è
stata presentata dai vari libri i vari
film di fantascienza di macchine
intelligenti che vogliono dominare il
mondo vogliono riduce in schiavitù e
dominare anche noi invece dobbiamo
abbracciare dobbiamo pensare a questa
intelligenza artificiale e soprattutto
la sua applicazione in biologia come
un'enorme opportunità un'opportunità per
il nostro futuro il futuro nostro e del
nostro pianeta
grazie